she was just a fixture to the school my
husband's being a governor here for ten
years and she was a became a friend but
she's just such a person I would say
that you always knew you could talk to
her and she got my son through so many
exams that I think he may have failed
this Shanna pushed him last year
she really was a great teacher and a
lovely little person what what drove her
to be a a teacher for so long 40 years
in one school I don't know we we an it
wasn't just a job she was just one of
those people who took the job and made
it a life's ambition she what she felt
for every child and she wanted every
child to do what they could do and she
got them there you know whether it was a
CRNA she got them to where they need you
arrived at school and inherited your she
was she was just amazing I was just
saying when you look back over your
school life she was a constant present
she was always there she was a rock for
so many people she's just she was
inspirational she just she made you want
to come to school to know that she was
there and if you had a problem in year
11 it's a hard time for everybody in
year 11 it's your exams but she just she
had time for every single person it
didn't matter what you've done the day
before why you were going back after
school she was just there she would get
you through how would she help you she
just just any problem which I mean I
just remember her chasing us down the
halls and saying it's quiet practice
come on girls get back into class it's
quite practical and it's just she was
she just helped her she was just been
there I just made you feel safe